who exactly are the birds of prey and
what do they have to do with Harley
Quinn it's not as cut and dried as you
might think
join us as we explore DC's number one
squad of super heroines from their
origin story to their ever-changing
lineup from the Justice League to the
Fantastic Four superpower team-up sub in
part of the genre for decades sometimes
a headline in past like a Batman and
Superman in DC's long-running Wells
finest title often their sprawling
collections of aliens shapeshifters
super soldiers and psychics as in The
Avengers
occasionally they're a grab-bag of
misfits such as The Suicide Squad the
outsiders and the Doom Patrol generally
speaking most of these groups have been
around for a while to the point of being
adapted to other mediums sometimes more
than once the birds of prey in contrasts
are a fairly new invention born in 1996
in the Chuck Dixon and Gary Frank
one-shot Black Canary Oracle birds of
prey the team didn't get their own
ongoing book until 1999 that's run of
comics largely defined by writers Dixon
and Gail Simone continued until 2009
numerous reboots of flourished and
floundered the most recent being a
Batgirl and the birds of prey which
debuted in 2016 as part of DC's rebirth
events but it was cancelled in May 2018
despite this current absence of the team
the birds of prey are still regarded as
a major player on the DC stage a
designation made ironclad by the birds
of prey movie however removed it might
be from its comics origin sure the birds
are young compared to the Justice League
but that doesn't mean they haven't made
a splash of their own as far as
superhero names go birds of prey is
pretty great it implies the team's
majority to all female lineup without
being condescending it stands out when
compared to other DC team names
it's an OC approach of the birds
themselves to the criminals they pursue
that of hunters confident in their
ability to track trap and capture their
quarry in a genre littered with three
saccharine or off-putting the seductive
monikers for its heroines and their
organizations birds of prey is a
standout winner
readers will nuts however find the name
very often within the Comics own pages
it wasn't until issue number 86
published a full six years after the
series inception that anyone and the
titular team actually spoke the name
aloud prior to invading the helicopter
that should bother for the team
is in the Blake aka Lady Blackhawk
maintained we need a name this agent
Singh has got no zing so what about
being the birds of prey canary and black
hawk that's easy and the name Huntress
fits though the name did show up in its
own title and others it's nowhere near
as openly used as that of say the
Avengers or the Teen Titans
but given the birds most clandestine
approach to crime fighting that's likely
for the best so who are the birds of
prey their ranks have grown and shrunk
dramatically over the course of the
group's existence it's two constants
have been the women who headlined the
1996 one-shot Black Canary and Oracle at
least until Barbara Gordon became
Batgirl again their relationship was as
electric as it was supportive a complex
clash between the former a martial arts
master with an idealist streak and the
latter a steely realist and master
hacker tempered by everything from the
travails of super rock romance to
disability their bond from the
foundation of what would go on to become
one of DC universes premiere teams but
to join them in their crusade well often
there was Huntress a vigilante with a
crossbow and no patience for Falls and
then there was Lady Blackhawk member of
a world war two ERA group called the
Black Hawks who was ripped from the
1950s after the zero hour events and
able to pilot just about anything many
others floated in and out of the group
big Barda katana and judo master are but
a handful of those who have claimed
Byrd's membership over the years but
beyond the main fourth there were few
who stayed for long this didn't just
keep the team multi-talented and
flexible it made the book enduring ly
entertaining readers never knew who
would show up next and what stories
might arrive with them upon rummaging
through the birds comics history curious
movie fans will immediately realize
something odd even though she's the lead
at the 2019 movie Harley Quinn isn't
really found within the birds of prey
comics as a member of the team her
friends and lovers put in an appearance
or to poison ivy was a member of the new
52 bird from the first issue and
Catwoman had lined the birds of prey
manhunt miniseries both Harley Quinn
never does at least not in an official
group capacity comics often go through
changes on their journey to cinematic
adaptation ranging from the minor to the
massive remember when Halle Berry's
Catwoman was brought back from the dead
by an Egyptian Mau bearing abilities
from the goddess bast
good-few anticipated
birds-of-prey movie starring an anti
heroine with little if any connection to
the titular team psychologically
speaking vengeance rarely brings the
catharsis we hope for yeah are we ready
this isn't the only departure from the
source material however Cassandra Kane
goes from bad family member to street
kid hard-bitten Gotham detective Renee
Montoya is in the mix and criminal
kingpin black masks typically a Batman
and Catwoman villain act as the byrds
antagonist but therein lies the beauty
of the comic-book movie
it offers bright new visions of beloved
favorites though the birds of prey are
certainly best known for being heroic
team full of do-gooders their ranks have
been filled out more than once by those
less morally inclined Lady Shiva a
ruthless assassin and a mother of one
time Batgirl Cassandra Cain was perhaps
the best example of this brought to the
birds but a death of a sensei that Shiva
shared with Black Canary she became an
out-and-out protagonist as a woman with
a past involving violence and an
unceasing desire to push herself beyond
any and all limits
Shiva fit well alongside the series of
the characters she never became squeaky
clean nor even all that consistently
heroic but the hearts could be glimpse
beneath the grime and blood more Ruffin
in the pages of birds of prey than ever
before most affecting of all was her
relationship with Black Canary to call
them friends implies an ease and
closeness that doesn't quite fit but
their shared training and history
brought them together with drinking
buddies sparring partners and sometimes
comrades
this willingness to embrace characters
with murky intentions as capable of
greatness was a series biggest strength
and truly what made it a modern classic
of DC Comics what mattered in birds of
prey wasn't where Lady Shiva had been it
was where she was going for all this
innovation 20 19 s birds of prey is not
in fact the first live-action screen
adaptation of the titular team that
honor belongs to the short-lived 2002
birds of prey TV series which only add
13 episodes on The WB before it's
cancellation and to say this adaptation
was loose is an understatement
a metahuman herself with powers to open
hidden doors to the mind powers that she
is only beginning to explore
fascinatingly this dramatic departure
from the comics Canon has something in
common with the birds of the 2019 film
Harley Quinn in the TV series however
she wasn't the gleeful misfit in the
golden jumpsuit she was being set up as
a show's main antagonist audiences never
discovered how that story would have
turned out but at least they ended up
with a whole other birds linked Harley
to enjoy Justice League Unlimited was
beloved by fans for its smart writing
bold storytelling and crisp animation
but in a DC Animated universe were those
sterling qualities are the norm it takes
a little something extra to put a show
over the top but Justice League
Unlimited that came in the form of its
deep dive into the murkiest depths of DC
law no carrot show is too obscure to
slip in no arc to weird - it's apt this
was of course tremendously satisfying
for longtime fans but also with the
light to newbies many young viewers
first encountered the likes of Fire and
Ice
Booster Gold and Aztec and watching the
celebrated series
sadly the birds of prey never managed to
make the cut but not as it turns out for
lack of trying
producer Dwayne McDuffie having enjoyed
the comic series pitched an episode
centered around the team birds writer
Gail Simone wrote a script in which
Barbara Gordon crates the persona of
Oracle who works remotely with Huntress
and Black Canary but the character
writes involving Batgirl was so
prohibitive that she had to be taken out
of the story not interested in making
quote a halfway birds of prey the crew
decided to retool and the episode double
dates became a beloved caper involving
Black Canary Green Arrow Huntress and
the question too bad for the birds but
very good for the viewers
[Music]
you heard right Batman The Brave and the
bold was well loved for its wholehearted
devotion to the spirit of the Silver Age
after all it was made by a casting crew
eager to bring all their favorite DC
characters into the mix naturally the
birds of prey showed up but not as one
might expect in an episode entitled the
mask of matches Malone Black Canary
Huntress and Catwoman found themselves
cornered on say to the iceberg lounge
Awards a hole for super villains and
their assorted henchmen briefly frozen
by the glittering Glee evil and sandwich
the women railed in person to a close
harmony song titled birds of prey any
ideas just one hit it the Sun gets more
to do with the various seas
super-powered men in their lives and
anything they were doing themselves and
it was mostly meant as a way to get
through to a Denham Nisha Batman but the
song rocketed to online in for me
immediately after airing in Australia
due to the innuendo laid in their ex the
bus was so loud the song had to be
edited before airing in the United
States but the Internet's memory is long
indeed and birds of prey and that slight
commentary lives on in the hearts of
fans worldwide the DC Universe has bad
guys can be plenty scary
what would the likes of Joker Lex Luthor
and Deadshot running around things can
get pretty grim in a super heroic
universe like the time Joker cut off his
own face and pinned it to his cell just
to make a statement the grotesque can
gain a gargoyles wings in the realm of
comic books able to fly to new heights
of horror but the villainy of birds of
prey was considerably more downbeats
oh sure guys if names have a calculator
squared off against the birds more than
once but the evils of bird's face were
much more in line with that of the real
world
human trafficking terrorism and human
rights abuses were the order of the day
within those pages the first story of
the series in fact involved the
destabilization of a small country and
that subsequent use as a lawless haven
for the disreputable elite the birds may
have worn capes but they face malice of
a very familiar sauce birds of prey was
massively ahead of the curve weiter Gail
Simone has gone on record as conceiving
Black Canary as bisexual though her
attempts to make that textually over to
a stymied nevertheless she managed to
make it clear that her version of the
birds of prey was one with the LGBTQ
characters
which was evidence most explicitly by
the characters savants and crios an
entitled heir and a former KGB operative
respectively the villainous pair
transformed into good guys over the
course of the series and when creates
feelings for savants were revealed they
became a couple
take note Hollywood birds of prey was
way ahead of the curve check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
comics are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]